>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Music ]
>> My name is Chhatra
Bahadur Khatri.
I work in rural education
in [inaudible], Nepal.
I'm involved in [inaudible]
Nepal since last two years.
I work as a program director.
I oversee all the programs
offered in Nepal.
[inaudible], Nepal has been
working in Nepal since 1991
as a non-profit organization,
and [inaudible] Nepal started
as community libraries to improve
the literacy of the peoples
and to change the language of the
community people in the Nepal.
So, it is useful to all community
peoples naturally are reading
and writing, and we believe
that community library is not only
the house of books, but it is the,
it is the starting point
of the special things
in community development.
So, we also do some programs and
training sources to the community,
and that is some sort of
[inaudible] are using the libraries.
And some programs we
established after the setting
up the community library.
Once the library is established,
we provide a need basis trainings
and some programs, and we give
the training to the women.
We focus for them, a literacy
program, a literacy program
and education program because
education is the basic things
and fundamental thing to
do within the community,
and we focus the literacy programs.
Similarly, we focus for the women
development programs, women involved
in the programs because it's still
[inaudible] and 43% of the women
in the Nepal are illiterate
until now.
And as the social norms,
their community women
and builders [phonetic] are not
encouraged to read and write,
and they, even they are not
allowed to go out, outside.
So, we focus for women
involvement also.
And another thing is that
we focus for the [inaudible]
because icity [phonetic] is
generally is across working teams,
and we also provide icity
[inaudible] the community people
for providing the email,
Internet, and some basic training
of the community free of cost.
These are the main program
and a very important this
practice we are doing is
that practical answer programs,
practical answer programs helps
to communities access to
the information, knowledge,
and the technology, and they get
to answer what they are feeling.
We provide the response
of the other voices.
These are the main programs.
We have raised to 1.9
people suffered in Nepals
through 56 community libraries,
and we have produced 124 villages
of Nepal, and we have at least to 29
districts out of the 75 districts,
and this where programs are library,
community library programs
are designed
to solve whole the
community, and we give service
to all levels of the peoples.
Besides that, we have also some
focus programs to women empowerment,
as I already mentioned, and
children and marginalized people.
People are, we will be
behind some in some villages,
the people are not in [inaudible].
So, we also progress for
the marginalized people.
This literacy program
and [inaudible] program,
as well as the factory [phonetic]
lesson program has a help
to be their community library, very
important, and people are coming
to need our, need support to come
to libraries to read and write.
They come for and learn something,
and they come for to get some
answer of their [inaudible].
So, the credibility of their
community life has been increased,
and the people are more
committed to visiting the library
because of these programs, and we
want to see a well-informed society
in Nepal, and there are
more than 4000 villages
about to have literacy,
a few villages.
So, we want to make
a library one place,
one community library in Nepal.
That is our vision.
But we want to position
that, the [inaudible],
because community library is
a, that is [inaudible] access
for developments and
centers for their knowledge,
and it is one of the starting point
of their community development.
So, we want to build more community
libraries as fast as possible,
and then we also want to establish
the sustaining enterprises
to sustain the community libraries
because it cannot be
sustained without, themselves.
So, we have also a project
that we establish sustaining
enterprises together
with the community library.
And this way we want to establish
community library in the future,
and we also want to
expand our ICDs [inaudible]
in the community libraries,
and we also want
to expand all the practically
[inaudible] lines of programs.
That's why we need
the community library,
build the community library
using the very effective way,
and we also are thinking that
what would be the innovative idea
to inform the local people
to our city in the future.
We are always looking for that also.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.